[Music]
hey everybody
it's monday yep how many people are in
here not worrying one person is coming
four four or five
are people not are not down with the
bert reynolds
[Laughter]
they're starting to pile in okay they're
more of them start piling are we gonna
are we gonna make a burt reynolds
trifecta and like watch another one
tonight and like yeah we'll i'll [ __ ]
piss them off
[Laughter]
this one was actually a good one
sharky's machine was very good i like
yes i like is this a great deal it's i
saw it when i was a teenager i think and
i didn't really remember much about it
that's the thing i kind of feel like and
maybe this was uh why bert ended up
doing this movie in 1981
is that
i kind of always associate him with kind
of like smoking the bandit type rolls
you know what i mean where they're
always kind of like funny and there's
car chases and you know there's all
southern stuff
and i guess like when he did this he was
kind of trying to get away from that so
for a long time
and i guess like i have to say the cover
art for this and the poster and
everything probably didn't help
um
so for a long time even though i knew i
saw this movie i still had the
impression that it was like one of those
like funny bert reynolds movies and this
is absolutely not funny this is like a
really dark like a noir
cop thriller yeah um detective no
yes they call it a
no uh detect it's neo noir
neo noir detective foot
yeah kind of like uh
i saw a lot of parallels with blade
runner
yeah it did have like a little bit of it
which is a weird thing to say but it
does have a little bit of a a little bit
of a blade runner vibe too imagine if
blade runner was set in the uh very late
70s early 80s
in atlanta
and atlanta it's still a southern you
know bert's from from georgia this is
still a southern
story or he directed this [ __ ] and he
did it right it's still a southern story
but atlanta is kind of like the chicago
or
or new york of the south you know it
it it has a real big city feel to it
and he's a narcotics detective
who um they take him off of that and
they put him on the vice he doesn't
really like it
but he gets wrapped up in this damn
human
human trafficking
ring
and one thing leads to another weird
[ __ ] happens to it
and i was like i was watching what was
sharky's machine is it his car or the
gun or whatever no it's not his group
his crew is his crew that's what
sharky's machine is
his uh his buddies and he's got uh
two other real cool cop buddies and then
a boss and the uh and a couple other
side players and they crack this case
with these uh weird
weird human traffickers
and then there's like
kind of apparent there's in a couple
places kind of like a paranormal
undercurrent to some stuff because i was
i was thinking more about that later but
i'll get to it later it's
i don't know if it's supernatural but
it's kind of eastern philosophy to some
of this stuff
slasher fred said this movie starred the
late charles derning that's right he was
known by many rambo fans for playing the
bigoted sheriff in the original first
blood yeah charles darning was in a [ __ ]
kind of stuff yeah actually i really
enjoyed him in this he kind of plays
like the head of the vice squad and all
he does is just like scream and have
like a conniption fit and everyone's
like jesus [ __ ] friend he's just like
just [ __ ] screaming it's so [ __ ]
funny if you like bullet you'll like
this one
if you liked blade runner you'd like
this one
um what else movies would were there
parallels with
i don't know it's weird because i kind
of feel the weird thing about this movie
is that
it has like a lot of the noir like cop
thriller tropes
but then he kind of like subverts them
too sometimes burt reynolds is like this
wasn't the first movie he directed
because he directed gator right
and um
but i guess like he like i said he'd
been wanting to do something that wasn't
as comedic although he initially wasn't
going to direct this one he actually
asked john borman uh the guy that but he
was working on excalibur yeah at the
time so he was like no i can't do it so
he's like why don't you just direct it
burt and he's like yeah don't mind if i
do so bert decided to direct it and he
maybe because he's an actor he kind of
comes at things like a little bit
different and i don't know i kind of i
kind of dig it another one this kind of
reminded me of is a little bit like
black rain if you like black rain yeah
yeah
it's good it's real good um
there are a couple little slow spots
here and there but it doesn't it's
supposed to it it's it's a neo-noir it
has kind of like some romantic
undertones here and then
but they're kind of like melancholy
uh it's just weird you got to see it and
then instead of like in blade runner
instead of like vangelis and sax music
coming in
it'll have like some
70s sounding kind of like disco
will kind of come in but it but it
serves the same purpose it's kind of
weird kind of melancholy disco kind of
like
one of those cop series from the set
late 70s kind of like what was uh
what was that famous cop well like
streets of san francisco yeah or or was
it like douglas in that or a very young
lady yeah just not streets of san
francisco what was the other one night
chord or no not night court no that was
a fun that was it was it was a
cop
series from that time i i forgot what
it's called now it's on tip my tongue
but they had a
they had a uh a theme song that was kind
of like that seventies
yeah
the theme song of this is uh by the
crusaders i think it's called street
life yeah and uh yeah it's a fantastic
song i really like yeah
yeah and what's weird is that uh his uh
one of his partners there he's he's the
dude what was the name of that dude he's
from the um
he was from a
man who fell to earth played the cia
bernie casey yeah what's his name
bernie casey bernie casey yeah bernie
casey is kind of like his he's been at
five times yeah bernie casey is kind of
like his best friend in this
and uh
he's always trying to he's unusual he's
not like the regular guys in in in
sharky's machine in in the unit
he likes japanese food and he's into
eastern philosophy and
indigo which was pretty weird for 1981
yeah for a cop to be in yeah eat sushi
and stuff and he was uh into kind of
like atlanta
powers of the mind
and um
well make a long story short is a time
where sharky has to fight basically
ninjas
okay they're either yakuza but they're
kind of like they they do something well
when they came in i was like and then
two ninjas appeared yeah they're not
like they didn't have the whole like
full-on ninja gear but one of them did
have like the nunchuck things
yeah there's like a whole torture scene
here and there and other weird [ __ ]
happens
but then later on in the in the man i
don't know if i want to spoil it because
a lot of people haven't seen it but i
mean well it's old and it's kind of a
classic so i don't mind too much
the bernie casey character
said that in one part during this final
chase and it's kind of like the end of
blade runner where they're
chasing uh roy beatty roy batty the the
the replicant around and the the bad guy
who's this assassin
he's got something wrong with him he's a
he's a junkie and he's he's immune to
pain but he's also kind of like a psycho
and he may have some kind of a slightly
supernatural
way about him it's kind of like he
disappears and reappears but is it just
your imagination is he really is it just
dexterity is he
is it just you losing yeah they kind of
leave it very ambiguous henry silva
plays him by the way and he's just kind
of like this
lunatic yeah um and he's he's like a
coke head right or you know he's like a
he's a druggie and heroine and
everything i think so yeah and so he's
like a crazy person but yeah he does
there are a few
parts in there where
it does seem like he gets shot a bunch
of times and he's like still
walking around and you don't know if
that's just because he's like all
hepped up on the goofballs and yeah he's
just you know kind of denied he's like
super human but or if there's like some
other kind of weird because there is
kind of it's not like a huge thing but
there is kind of like this little
undercurrent yeah of course supernatural
maybe supernatural but i don't want to
oversell it right no it's just it's very
subtle it's plausible deny bill yeah on
some stuff there's a part where the
bertie casey
character is he's all shot up and he's
lead up against the wall and the bad guy
comes around and [ __ ] points a pistol
right at him he's been killing everybody
and he points it out of his face and
goes and screams but doesn't pull the
trigger yeah and then he does it again
and then he doesn't pull the trigger and
he's and then he feels like he can't
yeah and then he walks away
and then later on
bert was like you know what happened he
goes and he goes i tried to become
invisible
well there was like a big long scene
between the two of them earlier where
bernie casey was talking about
um like a domestic case that he had done
like early in his career and how the
dude was pointing a gun right at him
yeah and he's like and i he's kind of
like an eastern philosophy type guy
right so he's like i made myself like
invisible in a way yeah and he was kind
of like talking about that it's like a
really good like conversation so then
you wonder you saw it happen on camera
did he somehow cloud the mind of the bad
guy in in yeah you don't know or was the
bad guy just [ __ ] crazy and jacked up
on drugs you don't know yeah it could go
either way but i like that because
i can i understand bert's [ __ ]
gestalt you know i understand what he's
it's like it is still essentially kind
of a southern
story even though it doesn't really have
a southern feel to it it does
you're watching it you go this is in the
south somewhere
i couldn't figure out where it was and
then it i looked and it was atlanta they
never tell you i thought it was atlanta
at atlanta like because i saw the one of
the bus and i thought it said marta on
it m-a-r-t-a that's the atlanta bus
because my sister lives in atlanta yeah
if you guys don't know compared to you
know the south you know the north in in
the west to call us the bible belt but
really what it really boils down to is
the south has a long history of
belief in the supernatural and
superstitions and
you know this is where voodoo and [ __ ]
came from and
so it fits so it's bert khanna
i think paying a little bit of homage to
kind of the superstitions of the south
that
our belief in the paranormal or the or
the belief in the possibility of this of
the paranormal i believe that's what
what bert was trying to do in this i
mean that that's definitely was trying
to do based on those on this story i
liked it but it was deniable
yeah it had plausible deniability dude
might have just been [ __ ] crazy
and didn't pull the trigger yeah but
he he definitely did
he definitely didn't become invisible
because i could see him yeah okay
but did he somehow using
kind of like the power of will
interfere with the other guy's ability
to damn yeah i thought that's what they
were getting that's what i think they
were getting at
which uh cause that tied back to the
story that bernie casey was surrounded
the character's name was arch by the way
yeah art she has right but um so our
character was bernie arch may have had
a gift i believe that's what the story
meant
yeah yeah i thought it was cool very
cool but yeah so it's very out of place
in the story but it works
well this is kind of one of the ones we
were talking about this a little bit we
were talking about malone too and we
really liked malone um although this is
much better i kind of feel like this is
um a lot better than malone i kind of
feel like yeah this is pretty
universally um this was pretty
critically acclaimed when it came out
and still is and of all the movies that
he directed he didn't direct that many
it's a five six seven somewhere like
that um this is generally regarded as
his best one this is more on par with
black rain
yeah
um it's there is some humor in it but it
is very serious and it is very it was
actually surprisingly
violent yeah um and not just violent and
like people getting shot i'm talking
about like violent as in
you know a woman getting shot right in
the face and you're like seeing it and
bert getting his fingers cut off and
[ __ ] like that so there's like some kind
of gory [ __ ] in here too which surprised
me actually there's a lot of parallels
with this story
and blade rudder blade runner has a
different look to it it's blade runner
has a darker tone but if you like blade
runner you'll like this
this is almost kind of like what if
blade runner was a true story
that's kind of what yeah kind of what it
felt a lot of things that happened in
blade runner also happened this one
like the scene with rachel when
deckard basically slaps rachel around in
order to get sex out of her remember
that [ __ ] blade runner you're like
what the [ __ ] is happening here [ __ ]
like that kind of happens in this one
between him and
basically this [ __ ] sex slave
but it
it's not as weird as in blade runner
because if you know what blade runner
was about [ __ ] neither deckard nor
rachel were humans they were both they
were both replicants
they weren't human
i don't think they'd ever had sex
they didn't know how to
well they were
in the story they um
they were only all their memories were
artificial but that's talking about
another movie so they kind of like
didn't know how to behave
and this one
he kind of slaps her around during uh
interrogation
because he's gotta find out
who her basically who her pimp is and
she's protecting him it's a weird story
weird threat it's good though yeah i
mean okay so let's give like a broad
outline of the plot in case you guys
haven't seen it grantor said i was in
seventh grade when sharky's machine came
out it had everything for a 12 year old
to love comedy violence and nudity yeah
yeah there is some comedy in it but the
comedy in it to me seemed like subtler
yeah uh i actually really liked the
whole crew his machine if you were like
it's because i like that he
um i was reading this one review that i
thought was like very perceptive that
said the cool thing about burt reynolds
like directing himself in this is that
even though he's playing kind of a
stereotypical like tough macho cop he
actually kind of subverts that trope a
little bit as well and allows himself to
be like really vulnerable in some scenes
like especially the scene where he gets
like his fingers cut off and stuff like
that which is great
he's also they said he's also like not
egotistical in the sense that he
surrounds himself with these other
characters the other crew members of his
crew that are like kind of more
interesting than he is yeah which uh was
actually good i think it's like a really
good ensemble piece yeah
and that that reminds me again
in blade runner
deckard got two of his fingers broken in
this one he gets two of his fingers cut
off there's a lot of [ __ ] yeah
parallels and i don't i got to check the
dates i don't know
well this was actually it's based on a
novel okay uh that came out in 1978
by william deal so this is william deals
first novel and apparently what happened
was that sydney sheldon who's also a
writer sent bert a copy of that novel
and said hey this novel's pretty good
like why don't you read it so he read it
and he said oh i really like he said it
seemed very quote unquote cinematic and
he said it also reminded him of the
movie laura which was a film noir which
is was burt reynolds favorite movie from
like 1944. so he said well i want this
to be my next uh project because he
liked like the noir aspect of it so so
they're probably just using a lot of
tropes that all noir films use well yeah
i mean there is kind of like a formula
that that you go with movie starts off
look the movie starts off uh bert's on a
with his old narcotics unit he's doing a
drug bust it's almost kind of like uh
the way eddie murphy uh starts off over
the hills cop with the damn truckload of
cigarettes it's similar to that yeah
he's like undercover he's undercover
eating this he gets blown and all of a
sudden he's gotta [ __ ] go go hate
[ __ ]
um but what i really liked about that
opening scene is that when they showed
bert
undercover
he's you see him like you never seen him
before he's got a full beard
that's kind of short and he's got short
hair and he looks cool as [ __ ] with a
big looks a bit like sean connery yeah i
thought like yeah he looks cool and she
comes around that same i wish he would
have stayed that way but
after that mission was over he shaved
his beard off and he just had the old
bert ronald's mustache yeah but he
actually looked cooler with a full beard
i was reading a
a review of this guy i found this blog
where he reviews like a whole bunch of
burt reynolds movies and the name of the
series is called riding the mustache
right
so i thought that was really funny like
all his burt reynolds orbeez are all
right and no no hair piece or pompadour
or anything yeah it's just like cropped
shorts short hair yeah it looks good
it's almost kind of like deckard's
haircut from blade runner it looks the
movie's cool very cool i liked it i'd
watch this one again because there's a
bunch of stuff i missed too
yeah it's it's a complex story but it's
not all that difficult to follow i
didn't find it all that difficult to
follow
um it's not as i mean the story in
malone was a lot more straightforward
this one has a lot more like you know
bells and whistles but i still don't
think it's that right it's really not
that well i don't mean that complicated
there's a lot of little things you that
that you have you can enjoy little side
things between two characters of what
they said you
know said to each other in the
background sometimes or on the side
that's kind of funny but it's hard to
take it all in because a lot of times
they're talking over each other yeah
it's supposed to be very realistic it's
almost like a robert altman movie where
everybody's just kind of like talking
over each other like conversations
because like you said it's supposed to
be very naturalistic yeah and so there's
like you know when he first gets sat
down device so he's on this he's on the
narcotics squad and i guess he's like
you know really good at that but then
like this uh his cover gets blown you
find out
about that later on like how that
happened but um he's so he's chasing the
guy everything goes tits up and while
he's chasing the guy the guy like takes
a hostage and goes on the bus and then
like a couple like the bus driver and
one of the people on the bus like ends
up getting shot i don't know if they
were killed
so it was just kind of like this big
[ __ ] up and so he gets demoted to vice
so when he goes down to the basement
where vice is you go down there and it
just looks like a [ __ ] circus you
know what i mean
it's like all these characters they give
him the shitty desk with garbage all
over it right there's the jail center
right next to the jail cell and there's
like all hookers and they're like
yelling about calling their lawyer and
it's just like so everybody on the vice
squad is like kind of a character and
like i said charles derning like plays
the head of the vice squad and he's just
like constantly screaming at what like
fuck-ups all these people are and it's
just really really funny so everybody's
just kind of like has conversations yeah
going at the same time so it's all like
very chaotic and bert is just kind of
like holy [ __ ] i can't be there i can't
believe i got like [ __ ] kicked down
here this is like really shitty but then
it ends up that one of the prostitutes
that they picked up
had a lead on this high class prostitute
uh domino who's played by rachel ward
and it turns out that she
has a link to a guy that's running for
governor of atlanta
and then it kind of so they kind of like
start
uh they put her under surveillance like
they have an apartment across from her
apartment and they're like watching her
and then it turns out that she's also
involved with like this you know drug
trade sex trafficking and all this other
stuff and um
so it turns out that like there's a guy
named victor
who comes to see her and then henry
silva's character
uh is kind of like the enforcer like
he's like the crazy guy that goes around
like killing people that need killing
so there's that so
so a lot of the middle part of the movie
interestingly it like after all the you
know characters are introduced is like
surveillance like burt reynolds and some
of his other members of his crew like
you know watching
uh this prostitute like in her apartment
and like the comings and goings so and
then like them just having like
discussions with each other which
actually sounds like it'd be boring but
it's totally not because like all the
characters are really interesting so you
really kind of like all their
interactions with one another while
they're watching her and then like burt
reynolds kind of ends up developing some
feelings for her
like while he's kind of following her
and going about her life and stuff and
then kind of feels the need to
sort of like uh protect her when [ __ ]
starts going pear-shaped
um
so yeah it's there's a lot like i said
there's a lot more stuff going on but
it's not terribly hard to follow i don't
think i didn't really scott johnson said
stick was the voodoo bert reynolds movie
yeah that one's on amazon prime too this
one we watched on amazon prime uh it's
not free it was 2.99 though you just
like would they had it
though yeah they had a bunch of burt
reynolds movies they had stick they had
stroke race they had um yeah they had
like a [ __ ] they had that one called the
end which i think it's like a black
comedy
yeah and i'm pretty sure he directed
that one as well unless i may be wrong
he was a
real estate agent who was dying or
something yeah
or something i think i remember seeing
that on cable back in the old days of
that being funny but you know we maybe
we'll get around to that one of these
days too but
um but i don't know it's just that this
one
i don't know i just really like this one
i just like the whole like i said
there's funny [ __ ] in it but the funny
stuff is just kind of like subtle like
one of the funniest things i thought was
when they were taking him down to vice
and the guy says whom he's like you want
to know what i think and pert's just
like no
light just like the turn of his voice
and it was just so it's just like funny
[ __ ] like that he does say funny [ __ ]
but it's not like
it's not like the
the bruce that's like you know smirking
at the camera kind of thing so i like
that he was kind of going in a more
serious route and this was like like i
said a lot more
violent and a lot more gory
than i was expecting like that finger
cutting off scene was like pretty
intense yeah it was good yeah good and i
recommend the movie i put it up there
with you know you know and often i
really love blade runner this is like a
southern blade runner or black rain you
know kind of like that too even though i
think black those both of those other
two movies of course were on a totally
different level visually you know what i
mean they were real expensive visually
black random blade runner but
totally in the way the stories are kind
of laid out real similar if you like
those two movies you'd like this one
it's good good movie yeah scott johansen
pointed out that uh yeah burt actually
called this movie dirty harry in atlanta
yeah which i guess it kind of is uh
better better than a dirty hair yeah
well honestly i i don't mind the dirty
harry movies but i do kind of feel like
they're more
simplistic i don't know i don't know if
i want to use that word because it
sounds like a negative comment
connotation this one like i said one of
the things that i thought was really
good about this one was that even though
burt reynolds character tom sharkey was
kind of like
you know the tough macho stoic cop guy
um he wasn't he was a lot more like
complex i think yeah and he was again he
was kind of like willing to
let himself show like vulnerability in a
way that maybe that maybe clint eastwood
wouldn't
to me i think he was a character a lot
like deckard harrison ford's decade he
was a lot like that
yeah he was clearly very flawed yeah um
and he had like a little bit like
remember that scene where he first takes
domino like to that house like his
parents house which he's been fixing up
and he was carving like a window seat so
he could like sit and like watch the
school across the street
and he had carved like a rose into the
wood and he was trying to like hide it
from her because he thought that she
would think it was like too girly or
something i don't know
but she was just she thought it was
funny that he was like embarrassed to
show her that he had like carved a rose
there like it wouldn't like it wasn't
cool enough you know i mean but i like
like little touches like that like that
there was actually
something you know else going on in
there than just like this tough guy
but yeah i kind of i liked that about it
as well
um i'm trying to think of like because i
know there was like something else now
rachel ward she wasn't against all odds
too wasn't she i can't remember what
else she was in she's a british actress
i think i don't know i didn't really i
didn't recognize her she um
well the bert said that uh
that they were taking a really long time
because he's like you know the person
that plays domino in this movie has to
be like
you know when you look at her you're
like yeah bam you know what i mean so he
was looking for somebody couldn't really
find her
and then
um rachel ward turned up on the cover of
a magazine as like the face of the 80s
and so then when he saw her in person
he's like yeah she's totally has to be
in the movie so like i said i'm pretty
sure she wasn't against all odds she was
then some other stuff too but he's like
he thought it was good because he wanted
the actress to be able to speak french
and italian
and she could
so it was kind of like a perfect fit no
need for me too says sharky sharky's
machine is heavily referenced on the
venture brothers animated show yeah yeah
adult swim
it's uh yeah it's kind of like part of
the background story or the lore scott
johnson says uh reynolds did direct the
end yeah i thought he did yeah
i remember that being funny but i
haven't seen it for a really long so
like i said it's a dark comedy like
about a suicide or something like that
no need for me says i haven't seen it
since i was a kid and have it blurred
with other reynolds films oh it's a good
film i think that's what happened to me
like i said i kind of feel like because
growing up i saw
smoking the bandit cannonball run and
stuff like that and stroke a race to a
lesser degree like so many times that i
think i always associated burt reynolds
with like funny [ __ ] or like funny car
chase
kind of comedy movies
and
now that we're kind of exploring some of
his other back catalog i was like a
surprise just how many serious movies he
did and how good he was at them yeah
he's good this is like
i mean it it came way later than bullet
but it's kind of like his version of
bullet it's good you know so far when
you say this is kind of like burt
reynolds version of bullet
yeah it's just kind of yeah
yeah i mean it's definitely a cop
a cop that's getting involved in like
some big kind of much larger like
corruption kind of cases yeah
you know i was it's just that kind of
thing no i was going to say that rachel
ward actually she uh
she got nominated for a golden globe for
this
so i mean this has
like so many character actors in it that
you will recognize yeah
i mean
like i said henry silva's in it [ __ ]
earl holloman is in it uh brian keith is
in it there's just like there's so many
[ __ ] people i think they said that
this is burt reynolds highest rated
movie that people think that this is it
is of all the ones that he directed i'm
pretty sure this is like the the most
well regarded and like i said i think in
general like most of the critics at the
time gave this like a really good like
roger ebert and all that like gave this
actually a really good review at the
time that it came out
um
doesn't fit the movie it really doesn't
um
like i said like serious like bullet
yeah i mean well like i said i kind of
feel like people still perceived bert as
like the funny guy yeah so they're
trying to make the poster look kind of
like it could be comedic yeah
potentially and this really isn't no
it really isn't coming i would have had
a poster like bullet or a poster like
black rain or something like that or or
you know or made it like a blade runner
poster but it looked really [ __ ] cool
that's that's that's
kind of dark and urban and you know yeah
made it look like like a noir poster i
mean because that's essentially what
this is
it's like a modern day noir yeah
detective type movie yeah but like set
in the south said in atlanta
so you know that's probably what they
should have done but you know i'm not
i don't work for the movie companies and
making the posters back then they were
looking at the old data from the time
and trying to sell it in the in those
days
so i guess they thought that was weird i
feel like that was kind of a problem a
lot though like in the 70s 80s maybe not
a big problem but i have like um
i have seen it happen before where
just the the poster art or sometimes
book covers too because i've seen this
happen too like especially stuff that
came out in the 70s or 80s like
absolutely does not fit yeah right uh
what because honestly like doing that
kind of that's an art you have to really
kind of like capture the the tone of the
[ __ ] like in your marketing materials
and sometimes
yeah i feel like the
the poster for this with like it kind of
had the neon but that kind of reminded
me of poor kids yeah
so and then they didn't have photos
which i guess they didn't back then that
was mostly i mean they did have photos
but they had a lot of like artwork of
painted and like the painted artwork
wasn't really that good yeah no and it's
just kind of like like look a wacky
ensemble cop thing that's kind of what
it reminded me this needs it's like a 4k
remaster re-release with all new [ __ ]
all new cover art and just you know what
i mean as if you were releasing this
movie today is today's market it you
know i mean you can make that you can
make that uh
uh that that blu-ray case look badass
well the blu-ray uh cover is actually a
bit better yeah okay the blu-ray cover
actually has like a large kind of like
stylized uh burt reynolds face
and then like in the background you know
that shot when he first sees domino and
she like kind of turns around and you
can sort of see through her skirt yeah
um it has like that shot yeah it has
that shot where she's like turning
around looking at him right like it's
small like in the distance but then like
his face is it's it's not great but it's
better it's better because the the
original one like looked kind of goofy
yeah you know what i mean it looked like
it was kind of like treading into like
police academy yeah not that wacky but
kind of more at that end of the spectrum
okay guns uh guns that show up in the
movie are uh pretty realistic for the
for the era
lots of uh three to seven magnum
revolvers uh
the uh when sharky first shows up under
cover he's got a damn um i think it's a
cult diamondback wasn't it a diamondback
or a python i think it was a diamondback
i don't know why you're asking me
well they said it they said what it was
i think it was a cult diamondback um
which is all three percent magnum
revolver
and they were they were commenting on it
and then uh
then it looked like there was some uh 41
magnum [ __ ] revolvers a bad guy had
one of those and then later on you start
seeing more automatics yeah sharky and
uh and his buddy what was it
what was what was his buddy's name again
mac no which one um [ __ ]
the bernie casey guy or the other
bernie casey arch arch that's right yeah
arch is uh
i think he had a i think he had a 1911
also he started seeing automatics come
out towards the end of the movie but um
you don't see any uh
i don't remember any kind of sub machine
guns or anything
maybe that guy did have one i don't know
but i just remember there were a lot of
revolvers in this
in 1911 so pretty cool pretty cool
oh i want to say to you fun fact you
know that uh that stunt where that dude
like fell off that really high building
yeah yeah um i believe this is according
to wikipedia uh still stands as the
highest free fall stunt ever performed
from a building for a commercially
released film okay yeah even though they
did like
a 20 or 30 story building yeah they
didn't actually use like for the long
shot i think they used a dummy but they
did actually do that stunt yeah but they
just the first part of it is actually
there yeah it's two different shots the
first part of the shot is a dude he's
kicking and screaming on his way down
yeah but then it clicks over to another
angle and it's a dummy obviously it's a
dummy yeah which i think i've left only
the first shot in but oh well
yeah what are you gonna do yeah i mean
but yeah they did actually do that it's
not like somebody did actually like fog
it was 220 feet yeah okay yikes yeah but
yeah scary
recommend the movie though man check it
out it's uh it's 2.99 on uh amazon
amazon prime yeah i don't know if you
can find it cheaper it's worth it it's
worth it though
yeah it's
i mean of all the burt reynolds movies
we've seen um i think this was my
favorite one and like i said it's weird
because i had seen it as a teenager
on cable but i didn't really remember
anything about it i think i was probably
like too young to appreciate it because
like i said i was i really liked like
his comedy [ __ ]
and then when i saw that i was probably
like well this isn't funny like what's
going on you know what i mean it was
like a like i said it has funny stuff in
it but it's more like subtle humor or
like kind of just situational
[ __ ] that happens or kind of like dark
humor it's not kind of like that
over-the-top like zany kind of [ __ ] it's
much more like a like a noir feel to it
yeah but i don't know i really dug it i
would actually wouldn't mind uh watching
it again at some point yeah you
yeah
and will um so you want to do another
another one for someone might as well
yeah we do which one do you want to do
do you know um like i said i'm trying to
think that amazon prime had
stick
and it had stroker ace
and it had the end i want to see if
there's stick or stroke or ace and it
even had one that was there's a bunch of
underwear yeah there was yeah i didn't
realize he was in i didn't know when he
was 2018 yeah well he died didn't he
didn't he die i don't know
i thought he died recently like in the
last couple years
am i wrong about that if you're i'm
sorry if you're still alive burt i'm
just
i thought that he died though like last
year or the year before
but he was in something in 2018. yeah he
died september 6 2018.
okay so he was so the thing that we saw
that's on amazon prime from 2018 was
probably his last thing yeah i guess so
yeah but yeah they have a bunch of his
movies on there oh fun fact too
is that you know the kind of like uh the
bouncer guy or the driver that was in
this l mongol yeah that's a mexican
wrestler yeah okay like in real life
yeah yeah they got put in the movie yeah
because i was like i thought it was
funny when they said his name but i was
just kind of like what he doesn't have a
name he's just like oh it was just
gangster
that was his gangster name but he's like
a really he's a mexican wrestler yeah i
just like i saw that too
yeah he's a lucha dory yeah that was
like pretty funny yeah but yeah so uh
we'll fight we'll find another burt
reynolds movie to
watch ladies and gentlemen stick or
something yeah we'll talk about that uh
tomorrow but yeah it's uh this was a
really good one i liked this one a lot
so yeah go to amazon prime pay 2.99 and
watch it and uh we hope you guys uh like
it so thanks for dropping by and hanging
about
hanging out with us talking about
bert the stash
[Laughter]
and we will uh see you guys again
tomorrow